today I'm finally doing a long-overdue
office tour this is where I do all of my
editing and I've been working on this
for a really long time so I'm so excited
to show it to you
finally it is almost ready there's one
thing that I've been waiting for to
complete this entire look and here it is
the missing piece this is the LG OLED 65
inch TV and I'm super excited about this
so we're gonna unbox it set it up and
we'll start this office door Maddie it's
okay you'll come see it's a 65 inch OLED
it's your favorite give it a sniff what
do you think learn about it no don't
learn about me you already know have I
cleared the TV yeah okay oh gosh I'm
gonna topple over what is in here I
think that's the stand that's definitely
the stand holy moly
oh my gosh geez I'm sweating I should
probably find the directions look how
thin this is this is so amazing I mean
like I've obviously seen the wallpaper
TVs before but this is all built-in and
this is gonna be the new edition but I'm
really excited about is I'll be able to
use this to monitor when I'm shooting
videos and also I can now hook up my
xbox to this they look like call of duty
and act like I'm editing what I know I'm
not
alright let's put this stand on so do we
need a screwdriver or does it come with
one this is actually really light I
gotta pick up the TV I can't play with
you right now because we got to take the
TV in the office one is it's finally
complete guys I can't believe I finally
get to show this to you I've been
working on this office for so long and
now officially the final piece of the
puzzle is here the new
it'll do levy 9 is wallpaper thin with a
floating glass bezel screen design
it features OLED self-lighting
technology each pixel controls their
luminance individually this ensures
those perfect blacks for an incredible
image with 4k cinema HDR Dolby vision
and Atmos this is a great TV for movies
Netflix and of course gaming it has a 1
millisecond response time and 12 point 9
millisecond input lag so if you're
looking to game on a larger screen that
this gives you great performance this
has the new alpha 9 intelligent
processor which uses a deep learning AI
algorithm to analyze millions of content
pieces this will provide you with the
best image and sound they also love how
easy it is that you can airplay right
from your iPhone your iPad or your Mac
it's supposed to be a part of the video
but what's happening right now bias is
I'm using this TV as a file browser for
all the media that we shot while we're
working on this video this was just
mostly b-roll but I share this amazing
[Music]
using your voice you can ask Google
assistant or Alexa built-in questions
while watching conversational AI makes
it seem more like you're talking to a
person rather than a voice assistant so
you can ask the Google assistant things
like search for Brad Pitt what was his
latest movie play it on the screen
instead of asking for each question
separately you're able to string along a
bunch of different commands to get the
result you were looking for so obviously
we've talked about the highlight of this
room and that's my new LG TV a lot of
times I'm shooting by myself but today
thankfully Tyler is here helping me
shoot this so this is great for either a
set up when I'm shooting myself or if
somebody else is helping as well because
I'm able to monitor and we can see if
we're focus and I can make sure from
godson fly away is there something I can
just fix it right up but it's also good
too because if Tyler's controlling the
second camera investigating cancer so he
can be basically monitoring in the
second camera and the main camera at the
same time what do you think most easiest
right amazing oh and over here of course
I have my router which is a such a
terrible place to put it I'm gonna find
a different location for it but for the
sake of this video I didn't have time to
find a longer take it what was it
connected somewhere else so that's where
it is and this painting behind me is
also one of my favorite parts about this
room this was custom painted for me I
commissioned Corey Basil's an incredible
artist
I was wondering something that's kind of
like an exposed wall but also with a
little bit of like rose gold and copper
kind of put into it he honestly captured
my vision so perfectly and it just it's
so great I love it it looks so good in
this room the second centerpiece which
is actually technically I guess the
actual center of the room is this desk
I love Restoration Hardware so I got
this matching desk and matching TV stand
I really wanted an executive style desk
which is one that you can kind of keep
in the middle and doesn't have to be up
against the wall one of the things that
I was hoping that this desk would have
was a little hole to put the cords in
but for some reason a lot of their desks
don't have holes for cables but just so
strange I'm just gonna sacrifice the
fact that there are cords hanging off of
my desk
the 18 core iMac pro that you guys saw
me unbox before and obviously it has all
of these space grey accessories and that
white cable is an Ethernet cable that
comes up to my jellyfish server and the
jellyfish server is what I added
everything off oh so with that I dumped
all of my footage onto it and I edit
directly onto that and I could also have
other editors connect to the jellyfish
at the same time and be editing off of
the server on other projects so it's
really really cool a lot of times what I
will do is I will dump the footage onto
the jellyfish and then since I do travel
a lot I take that footage with me on the
go with these drives and these drives
I'm just feeling obsessed with it's been
working out really really well I've also
got this razor microphone home pod and
this is a charging mat by Nomad and all
the charging mat I have a pair of air
pods and these air pods have one of the
Nomad cases on it it's like this really
nice leather case since I do travel a
lot I'm always traveling with my MacBook
and this is kind of interesting it
definitely looks like trash but I have a
Velcro on the back of my macbook so that
I can attach these hard drives to it
when I'm editing because I never want
those cords to get knocked out by
accident this is terrible looking but
extremely functional hi just seen from
the future got my 16 inch MacBook Pro
here when I shot this video originally
this computer wasn't even out yet we
didn't even know this was gonna be a
thing I mean in the rumors we did but
realistically didn't know it was real
it's been cool because now that this has
Catalina installed and I previously had
not installed Catalina on any of my
machines I can now use sidecar as I've
been testing out using my iPad also as
an external monitor but in my current
desk setup as you guys will see here I
can take what I have on my iMac and use
this massive LG TV as a file browser so
when I'm going through footage I can be
using that as a huge external monitor I
can also use it to preview my videos
this is something that I didn't realize
that I needed in my office until I had
it and now it is honestly
come true okay back to the video I've
just got a bunch of random things in
here
headphones pens they obviously needed
some black post-it notes with silver
sharpies hi
I was not messing around like this
entire office is just super dark if I
need to take some notes I have black
paper and again you can't write on it
with my silver shark and love editing
here in the daytime because I have a
mirror to my left which is also the
Restoration Hardware and as soon as I
saw that thing online I had to quickly
for the first time ever measure this
little portion of the wall because I was
hoping that it would fit and it does and
it's great because I have a window to my
right so it makes this room feel so much
larger than it is
I've got a few carpets here to hide
wires it's not really working that well
but it's I guess a solid attempt at
least this little chair setup over here
this is all from West Elm and this is
basically Maddie's chair the only
problem is this chair is kind of like a
velvety materials so Mady tends to leave
his little paw prints all over the place
but just totally fine it's okay he can
sit there he can do whatever he wants
does he want this chair yeah he can do
what he want my computer he can have
whatever he wants
this chair is also a custom chair from
Restoration Hardware I went and picked
the color of the wood the fabric I love
the way that the white kind of accents
everything else in the room definitely a
big fan definitely worth the wait
I'm shooting this video on a sony a7 3s
such a great camera especially for
autofocus but like that I'm using to
light up this room and I also use this
light in the other room where I shoot
and do unboxings it's the light matte
plus 4 and this thing is amazing I mean
it puts out so much light it works out
well here downstairs when I was shooting
kitchen videos I also have this light
back here I popped in some hue bulbs in
there so I can also change the color
temperature a blue or Savannah
blue actually looked really good I keep
that I also have some hue lights behind
the TV and I have a few other ones that
I'm gonna stall somewhere around here I
think maybe behind the mirror so that
pretty much does it for a quick little
overview of my office and is so excited
I absolutely love to just hang out in
here and edit and work and it is so much
more relaxing now that I have everything
set up there's only one final thing that
I have to do and that's set up my xbox
oh gosh I'm crazy when I play with game
absolutely insane I see you I see you I
see you do you see me nope get out look
at you oh come on please you're Brian
shield what do you think you are
I need to thank you again 2lt for
sponsoring this video and making the
rest of my office just come to life see
you guys later I'll put some links in
the description if you want to find out
more information about the TV and be
sure to subscribe and like this video
and let me know if there's anything else
that you think that I need for my office
I'll see you guys later
[Music]